[Music]
Lionel Shriver writes for her column in
this week's magazine about how the
political left and right in America will
react if their candidate loses this
year's election is violence on American
streets a possibility either way Lionel
joins me now LEL thanks for joining
spectator TV you write for your column
this week about a political conversation
that you had with your expat guests over
Christmas tell us about
it well we were trying to decide what
would be uh worse on the
ground um if uh Trump wins or Biden wins
in November um who who would be the
sorest
losers and um my the company I was
sharing was um
typically for most of the people I know
um liberal uh universally
Democrats and they were convinced that
the uh what we should really fear is the
reaction of the right if Trump loses
again that these are the people who have
all the guns and you know there's that
horrible president of January 6th and uh
so you know we'll be
it would be we'll be better off with
Biden as president but we would have to
pay for it with a horrible backlash on
the right and of course uh Democrats are
always claiming that uh democracy itself
the Republic itself is is in
danger um I differed I I I was the only
person who thought that uh if Trump
wins uh Not only would do are we stuck
with Trump but the left would be likely
to go bananas and I you know I've been
through this rehearsal before because of
course we play faced the same situation
in 2020 right so one of the reasons I
was relieved when Biden won was not only
that I had voted for him but uh I so
dreaded the response of the left if
Trump prevailed
well L let's look at your column and the
two possibilities that that you and your
friends broadly discuss your friends are
talking about the disgruntle Trump
voters how if they lose again they'll
feel the election was stolen again and
you could see some kind of repeat of
January 6 an attempted Insurrection that
could be even more violent you point out
that in the aftermath of George Floyd
you had Al be a minority but certainly
some protesters who turned very violent
and in places like Seattle and Portland
Oregon essentially took over parts of
the city in in a very violent Manner and
the point here being that in either
direction you you could see something
really quite scary I suppose the
meaningful difference though is that
Trump was the first president to
essentially say that he he would not
accept the results of the election the
Republicans were tested in 2020 and
Donald Trump and his supporters failed
Biden has not been tested in that way
the Democrats haven't been tested at the
presidential level in that way well we
don't really um we don't have the
evidence on the left because the left
has not been tested in this circumstance
I mean the the one bit of evidence we do
have is from 2016 and there was a
concerted four-year effort to deny uh to
effectively deny Trump the presidency
and to uh invalidate his election uh
which the the Democrats don't like to
remember because they are fixated on
Trump's insistence on invalidating 2020
but there is a a very there is a a
strong symmetry there um on the uh on
the left versus right you
know January 6 I I found it very
disturbing
um it was a horrific picture to
broadcast all over the world uh of the
US capital being in Ed by a a mob and so
I don't play it down exactly except that
I have striven mightily to maintain a
sense of proportion about it I don't
think it was an attempt to overthrow the
government of the United States it was
not well
organized it was unarmed um I don't
think there was any expectation in that
crowd that they would actually be able
to get into the capital they all you
know on the CCTV footage they all look
kind of amazed and and baffled and and
wondrous and they're taking selfies and
this this is not an army which is out to
overthrow any government um and if you
look at the
consequences uh the consequences were
mostly for the Democrats being able to
uh use that event politically as a cudel
and of course the people that they were
able to get hold of were
prosecuted I think quite
disproportionately um but in
comparison uh the riots after uh George
Floyd's death were they were all over
the country over 140 cities uh there was
fantastic Damage Done um massive arson
and
vandalism
um
and I and it went on for months so I
mean and and and as you noted the cities
like Seattle and Portland have never
been the same you know and and for the
most part these riots were allowed to go
nuts the law enforcement because it was
under attack ideologically because
that's was the defund the police
period laid back in a lot of
Metropolitan are is and just let it
happen and for the most part um the
people who caused all that destruction
have not been held to account either so
why wouldn't they do it
again so if I'm looking at
November then that's what makes me no
most nervous lonel you and I have not
been always painted in a nice light over
the past four three and a half years for
our open and public decision to support
Joe Biden in November 2020 and you and I
have spoken about this um when we' seen
each other in person here at The
Spectator offices that people will often
say to us oh gosh you must you must
regret that if you could go back to
election day surely you would recast
your vote for another person and and I
think both of us resly say no I wouldn't
and with the information we had and
certainly uh with hindsight with what
came on January 6th I I do not regret
that vote at all um I have I would I
would love to know your thoughts on that
if if if you have any s what I will say
though is I Joe Biden sold himself on
this idea that we might return to some
sanity that we might return to some
normality not in terms of any particular
piece of public policy just in the way
that we carry our conversations and
political debate it seems like we're in
a worse spot now perhaps than we were in
November 2020 um and I think that goes
back to the point you were making at the
start about how on Earth we're being
asked to choose between these two
directions perspectives and Men again
yeah I I guess I I agree with you that I
wouldn't take my boat back in
um that said I feel that I've been
victimized by a baon switch and that
everything that Biden promised he has
gone back on he's been anything but a
unifier you know all that screaming
about magga Republicans and he's been
he's he's increased the polarization and
he's certainly sold out to the far left
of his party
and I have not been happy with
his with his policies he's been
completely all of his appointments from
day one were completely controlled by
identity politics so that all that
mattered uh about his cabinet or his
staff were uh whether they were gay or
uh uh indigenous or black you know it's
it and it was advertised as much they
were never sold in terms of their
qualifications so that you know that
made me a little concerned from the
outset and and you know he spent too
much money um I'm I'm deeply
disappointed in Biden so I don't want to
people to misunderstand me that oh yay
go Biden um lenel nothing you've said
has come across is oh yeah go byen um
but
uh I I have to admit that coming up on
the election I mean I I always vote uh
even if I'm out of the country I make
sure to get an absentee
ballot I just I don't know what I'm
going to do I don't know whom I'm going
to vote for I cannot imagine voting for
either one of them and I I can see
myself choosing some third party who
doesn't have a chance
which is a kind of cheating it's it's
it's it's it's dodging your
responsibility if you vote for a third
party and you are usually in in the
context of of a American politics you
are usually tacitly supporting one or
the other candidates who has a prayer
right so I cautiously I cautiously
encourage it of course depending on who
the candidates are depending on the
party my perspective is H we don't owe
them anything we don't have to play
their game your vote is yours and if
nobody in the two major parties
convinces you I think you're welcome to
look elsewhere um I'm very curious as to
whether Americans might this time round
um there's always talk of third party
candidates they never really get
traction but this is a really unique set
of circumstances where we're being asked
to replay the most horrible election
nobody wants to do it again well I
I think that's probably what I would do
I but I I have to say I I don't feel
good about it and unless the poll's
really turn around and and I'm talking
about a third party whom I can consa
support and has a
chance then I then I would vote for that
person with a clear conscience but if
they don't have a
chance um then I think I'm kidding
myself and and and dodging dodging a
choice I don't want to make and
I and and I I do I think that's that's a
a kind of self-deceit it's
It's someone's going to be president
right so even though we don't want to
make a choice between these two men from
the perspective of right now one of them
is going to be president so we have to
decide which one is worse well ler we're
going to have to be in touch because I
think both of us are really quite
miserable right now we can send each
other like the worst of all the
candidates and then figure out who's the
least bad over the course of the year
but I'm pleased you got to spend some
time with Americans for
[Music]
Christmas